les matins de france culture 7h 9h
guillaume erner vous souvenez du monde
d'avant il était question de la
transition énergétique qui devait être
le coeur de l'acte 2 du quinquennat
alors ça c'était avant que reste-t-il
aujourd'hui de cela et le grand soir est
il arrivé pour l'écologie pour en parler
nous sommes en compagnie de jean marc
jancovici bonjour bonjour vous êtes
ingénieur consultant en énergie climat
enseignants à mines paristech et
président du film tant que chief project
jean marc jancovici qu'est ce que cette
crise change
à la question de la transition
énergétique alors en fait il ya une
transition énergétique cacher derrière
cette crise dont on ne se rend pas
compte ce qui concerne le pétrole avant
le avant la crise du lait coded
il s'est passé quelque chose il ya un an
et demi qui est passée un peu sous le
radar de la presse française qui est que
la production de pétrole dans le monde
s'est arrêté de croître
elle avait déjà commencé à faire ça en
2005 sur la période 2005 2008 on a vu le
résultat
économiquement là elle a recommencé à
faire ça et on avait déjà commencé à
voir le commerce mondial diminué on
avait commencé à voir la production
industrielle des pays ocde diminué et
ses locaux vides n'a fait qu'accélérer
cette chose là ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans le domaine du pétrole c'est
que la crise économique qui est survenu
pour cause de confinement a fait plonger
les prix du pétrole vers le bas
du coup les investissements qui sont
décidés cette année dans l'amont
pétrolier ont été divisées par quatre
pour le moment par rapport voire plus
par rapport à ce qui a été décidé
l'année dernière ce qui est une très
noble très bonne nouvelle pour le climat
les à me dire que l'offre de pétrole va
baisser et il se trouve que quand tout
va bien entre guillemets
quand ya pas trop vite pour le confiner
la quantité de pétrole disponible sur
terre c'est le premier facteur limitant
l'économie mondiale
donc ce que je suis en train de dire
c'est que la transition énergétique qui
va se faire sans qu'on s'en rende compte
c'est que la presse ne pourra pas
revenir au niveau de l'avant parce que
il n'y aura pas assez de pétrole donc
une partie du tourisme ne pourra pas
revenir
quoi qu'on fasse
une partie des déplacements ne pourra
pas revenir quoi qu'on fasse et une
partie de l'économie ne pourra pas
revenir quoi qu'on fasse ça c'est une
transition énergétique qu'on va devoir
gérer même si on n'a pas souhaité que
les gens qui s'intéressent à la question
des hydrocarbures qui sont aussi en
france le premier fournisseur d'énergie
pour machines nourriture pour machines
c'est à dire de l'énergie c'est ça la
vraie transition en fait qu'on va devoir
gérer la transition que tout le monde a
en tête qui est est-ce qu'on va planter
a cédé oliel et panneaux solaires pour
remplacer du nucléaire est une
transition gadget qui en veut dire qu'il
n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt pour faire
face aux grands défis d'avenir alors
celle là elle va très bien merci bien
parce que dans les premières mesures qui
ont été décidées par le gouvernement en
fait va très bien à double titre d'abord
parce que dans les premières mesures qui
ont été décidées par le gouvernement il
ya rassurez vous on va continuer à faire
ce genre de chose qui n'a en fait pas
beaucoup d'intérêt chez nous et qui
affaiblit l'économie parce que ça
augmente les importations mais sur dans
les autres domaines je ne pense pas
qu'on va faire grand chose de sérieux et
les du reste les secteurs qui vendent à
vous qui fabriquent plus exactement des
gens qui ont besoin de pétrole ou qui
utilisent du pétrole dont le secteur
aérien le secteur des constructeurs
automobiles font partie des premiers
secteurs qui ont reçu les aides très
significative et je n'ai pas entendu à
ce moment qui que ce soit dans le
gouvernement expliqué que ces secteurs
là de toute façon il allait falloir en
faire un peu moins de moins en moins
pour cause de diminution des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre jeu pas vraiment
entendu ça et au niveau européen ce
n'est pas beaucoup mieux
donc pour le moment la transition
énergétique ll est là celle qui n'a pas
d'intérêt et préserver celle qui avait
celle qu'il ya de l'intérêt n'est pas
spécialement rôle pas développée à la
faveur de ce qu'on doit faire
mais alors justement comment vous
expliquer cette tendance passée
dites-vous jean marc jancovici sous le
radar
il a été question également des gaz de
schiste puisque leur coût de revient est
aujourd'hui passée très nettement
au-dessus est du prix de vente des
hydrocarbures
comment expliquez vous cela ce qui s'est
alors comment j'explique quoi que le nom
quand vous disiez qu'il y avait un
phénomène qui était passé sous le radar
ça il faut demander à vos confrères de
nos villes le fait don d'un croisement
bien autre chose au sujet de deux de
cette baisse de la production puisqu'il
ya de nombreux gisements et qui aurait
été trouvé avec le gaz de schiste et les
états unis s'enorgueillissait d'être
aujourd'hui indépendant des importations
en matière d'hydrocarbures alors moi je
vous parle pas du gars je vous parle du
pétrole parce que le gaz et le pétrole
n'ont pas du tout les mêmes applications
dans le monde et en particulier les
transports sont totalement dépendants du
pétrole
98 % d'énergie utilisée dans les
transports c'est du pétrole
vous avez les camions à gaz des voitures
à gaz est très agacé quand même pas très
courant les gâteaux à gaz non plus tout
ça fonctionne au pétrole et le ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis en fait le
point intéressant pour ce que je suis en
train d'évoquer c'est le pétrole de
schiste aux états unis et manqua de gaz
en fait le pétrole de schiste c'est ce
qui a permis à l'économie mondiale de
repartir de l'avant après la crise de
2008 puisque qui elle même est une
conséquence du pic et du déclin de ce
qu'on appelle le pétrole conventionnel
donc là il ya un document de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie qu'était
publié en décembre 2018 qui a rappelé
quelque chose que les connaisseurs du
secteur savez qui est que le pétrole
dits conventionnels c'est tout ce qui
n'est pas pétrole de schiste et sables
bitumineux au canada est passé par un
pic en 2008 et depuis décline et en fait
c'est l'arrivée de ce pic qui a
directement causé ce qu'on a appelé la
crise financière des subprimes
ça c'est un cetain s'éteint c'est un
processus qui est très peu documentée
dans la presse française parce que la
presse française quand on lui parle
d'énergie s'intéresse essentiellement
l'électricité et donc la question qui
est pourquoi s'est passé sous le radar
ma réponse et j'en sais rien c'est pas
faute d'avoir essayé d'en parler mais
c'est un sujet qui intéresse la presse
pour des raisons qu'il faudrait creuser
plus avant et le fait que vous dites la
presse s'intéresse beaucoup à
l'électricité
le fait qu'on est d'une part beaucoup
évoqué la voiture électrique pour la
préco vite si vous croyez en l'existence
d'un après qu vie de jean marc jancovici
alors il ya de toute façon à la préco
vide je ne pense pas que l'humanité va
mourir demain matin par contre 7 après
qu vide il
être fait il ça va être un monde qui va
être très différent du monde d'avant
pour une raison c'est qu'on n'était de
toute façon en europe
on avait déjà commencé à rentrer dans
quelque chose qui était en tendance une
contraction structurelle de l'économie
physique donc je parle pas de l'économie
monétaire parce que vous pouvez très
bien avoir des effets de croissances qui
sont de la fosse croissance notamment
quand les objets se mettent à valloire
de plus en plus cher si vous allez
l'immobilier ce qu'on appelle des actifs
immobiliers se met à valloire de plus en
plus cher les actions se mettent à mal
voir de plus en plus cher etc c'est ça
vous créer artificiellement la
croissance tout un tas de raisons
techniques dans le calcul du pib mais ça
vous fait pas pour autant plus de mètres
carrés plus de voitures et si vous
regardez je le redis la production
industrielle ou la l'économie physique
où les mètres carrés disponibles
il se trouve que depuis 2008 il y avait
plus de croissance en europe
hélas ce qui va se passer c'est que nous
allons entrer dans une ère nouvelle qui
est une contraction structurelle de
l'économie
alors évidemment c'est pas du tout ce
que vous raconte les économistes mais je
rappelle que dans les modèles
économiques la croissance est une
hypothèse c'est un postulat de départ
sade et j'avais une démonstration de
modèles c'est pas une sortie c'est une
entrée donc le donc si donc nous allons
devoir raisonner en contraction
donc dans un monde dans lequel il y aura
pas de plus en plus de moyens pour gérer
de plus en plus de problèmes mais de
moins en moins de moyens pour gérer de
plus en plus de problèmes c'est ça le
monde vers lequel on se dirige et c'est
évidemment ça qui est le fait marquant
pour moi de ce qui va se passer dans les
décennies qui viennent
alors comment est il possible de
résoudre dans ce cas là cette contrainte
forte si vous dites que le monde se
contracte comment profiter de cette
contraction pour opérer une transition
énergétique et baron va opérer de
graduellement une transition de force
parce qu'on n'a pas voulu ou pas essayé
de faire c'est lé degré le fait que la
fête aurait une fin c'est quelque chose
qui est documentée depuis longtemps il
ya eu entre les arts au début des années
70 un travail d'universitaire du haïti
aux états unis qui a conduit à une
version vulgariser qui s'appelait les
limites à la croissance est qu un
certain nombre de gens d'un certain âge
on gardait dans la tête sous le nom du
rapport du club de rome
et ce travail disait que la recherche de
la croissance perpétuelle ne pouvait
amener que un effondrement du système
sur lui-même c'est bien qu'au bout d'un
moment vous avez la contraction de toute
façon parce qu'il n'ya plus assez pour
faire en sorte que le système hi han
croissant et bien à ce moment la
transition énergétique c'est une c'est
une diminution de la consommation ont
suivi ces services si on combat qu'on va
avoir de toutes façons dont les gens en
font moins de kilomètres consommeront
moins de choses
tout simplement parce qu'on l'aura on
leur a subi en france comme dans
beaucoup de pays européens ce n'est pas
du tout comme ça qu'on voit la
transition on voit la transition comme
étant dans un univers en croissance du
reste on n'arrête pas de parler de
croissance verte qui a voté la
croissance verte
donc moi je pense qu'on aurait pu aussi
voté le retour de larry potter
oui oui vous savez le monde politique
est d'habitude de confondre ses désirs
et nous aussi parfois et des réalités
donc le en europe on voit la transition
énergétique comme technologique dans un
univers en croissance donc on va faire
des voitures électriques de l'hydro
exactement celle des panneaux solaires
des machins des trucs et des bidules
tout ça dans un univers en croissance et
tout ira très bien
en fait la transition énergétique ça va
être devoir se passer de pétrole de
charbon et le gaz ce qui est déjà en
cours en plus en europe parce que notre
charbon ça fait deux siècles qu'on tape
dedans et la production de charbon en
europe est en déclin depuis des dizaines
d'années le gaz vient essentiellement de
la mer du nord qui est en déclin depuis
2005 et enfin le pétrole vient
essentiellement d'importation et ses
importations sont déjà orientés à la
baisse en tendance et dans les années
qui viennent
cette baisse va ça c'est qu'elle va
s'accélérer parce qu'il ya notamment la
russie qui fournit un tiers du pétrole
européen qui va passer son pic de
production enfin qu'il a probablement
passé avec le coach
donc tout ça va se contracter et donc
comme la quantité de machines qui
peuvent fonctionner puisque c'est sa
l'énergie
en europe a diminué l'économie va
structurellement se contracte et donc la
bonne question c'est comment on organise
une foire de sobriété et par ailleurs
comment est-ce qu'on organise la société
dans un monde dans lequel il n'y a pas
de plus en plus mais de moins en moins
et le grand danger pour les démocraties
vient du fait que pour le moment ce plan
b a jamais été réfléchi parce qu'il est
considéré comme jeu pourquoi inaudible
inenvisageable et donc on risque un
quelque sorte de chaos
parce que personne n'est prêt
personne n'a pensé ce monde là personne
n'a compris comment on pourrait
s'organiser dans ce monde là c'est ça
malheureusement la transition
énergétique qui présente cinq ans oui et
nous allons avoir et alors et dans ce
monde là on ne fait pas des gadgets cher
qui au plus ne résolvent pas de problème
on essaye d'aller à l'essentiel
alors l'essentiel c'est quoi le film
tant que vous dirigez et jean marc
jancovici ce shift project a établi une
méthode pratique pour accompagner cette
transition énergétique qu'est ce que
vous préconisez
alors vous aurez la réponse dans trois
mois ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a
décidé de lancer une mise à l'étude de
ce que serait un plan de transformation
de l'économie qui obéirait à une double
contrainte
la première c'est qu'il faut vraiment
faire baisser la dépendance aux
combustibles fossiles
d'une part parce que ça contribue à
dérégler un climat qui était stable
depuis dix mille ans et qui essaient
stabilité est très précieuse pour la
stabilité de nos sociétés juste un
indice pour en passant dans un monde qui
se réchauffe ray de quelques degrés
disons 4,5 contre d'ici à 2100 à partir
de 2000 70 il ya entre un et demi et 3
milliards d'hommes sur terre qui devrait
vivre dans des conditions qui sont plus
chaudes que le sahara actuelle vous avez
deux du même ordre la population donc
l'ordre du milliard qui vivrait donc
dans des zones dans lesquelles à peu
près tous les jours de l'année les
conditions extérieures seraient
mortelles fait trop chaud et trop humide
donc les gens puissent se tenir à
l'extérieur
tout ça dans un monde qui aura moins
d'énergie évidemment on va pas dire on
va climatisé partout qui est climatisé
dans les champs c'est complet donc le
donc donc le changement climatique est
évidemment quelque chose à éviter on n'a
pas idée de la disruption concert
présente c'est quelque chose qui est à
éviter
et par ailleurs même si on se fiche du
changement climatique en europe on va
avoir notre approvisionnement fossiles
qui va se contracter
parce que comme je le disais charbon
pétrole et gaz sont à la baisse de toute
façon donc ce que nous avons fait roshi
project c'est qu'on va regarder quels
sont les manières de transformer
l'économie dans ce contexte avec cette
contrainte là et avec une autre contexte
un autre en train de pardon qui est
qu'on ne tablent pas sur le retour de la
croissance
donc on s'est dit au travail il ya
maintenant trois semaines et on va
sortir un plan qui est en deux dans le
premier temps va arriver dans pas très
longtemps ses contreparties qu'on est-il
légitime de demander au secteur aux
entreprises qu'on va aider entre
guillemets en sortie de crise
oui évidemment les ct à ne pas repartir
comme avant puisqu'avant à cause de la
décrue énergétique a juste l'assurance
qu'ils vont prendre une baffe
donc la question c'est qu'est ce qu'on
leur demande en contrepartie donnez nous
des exemples
je vous donnerai des exemples en quinze
jours ci vont réalité vous à résister
maintenant tous les quinze jours jean
marc jancovici b il ya des politiques
qui ont leur rond de serviette france
culture mais si on prend si on prend le
système parce que c'est très contre
intuitive ce que vous nous dites vous
nous dites la période ne sera pas la
croissance là où vous suit aisément mais
précisément on se représente souvent la
transition énergétique comme une époque
d'investissement on se dit qu'il va y
avoir les ovations des habitations à
effectuer qui va falloir changer de
système par exemple passer de la voiture
au moteur à explosion à la voiture
électrique ça suppose des
investissements
est-ce qui va falloir est ce qu'on peut
faire sans jean marc jancovici
bah oui on peut très bien faire ça on
peut faire moins de voitures et à ce
moment les gens sont obligés pour le
coup de partager la voiture avec le
voisin donc ils sont obligés de ce
levier une demi heure plus tôt une demi
heure plus tard
et faire un crochet pour enfin voilà ils
sont obligés pas ce moment les gens sont
obligés de choisir éventuellement un
travail plus près de chez eux qui leur
plaît - ils sont enfin oui oui on peut
très bien faire autrement
après est ce qu'on a envie de faire
autrement c'est un autre sujet mais
est-ce que physiquement on peut faire
autrement que oui moi il se trouve que
je travaille à paris et j'habite à 25 km
de paris je peux aller à paris en vélo
ça me prend une demi heure ou une heure
de plus je peux le faire donc le la
question de s comptes ou bien sûr qu'on
peut avant le coc vide je vous aurais
demandé est ce que on peut supprimer 10%
d'économies française aurait sauté au
plafond ainsi commença à blé de fou on
peut le faire on va le faire cette année
donc il ya des tas de trucs qu'on peut
faire même si on n'a pas envie de le
faire justement il peut y avoir des
effets vertueux à la crise je mets ça
entre guillemets alors par exemple
l'industrie aéronautique et le transport
aérien ne vont pas repartir tout de
suite
par exemple le télétravail qui était
disons expérimental est aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus généralisée qu'est ce que
vous en pensez jean marc jancovici
adjointe salle ça je pense justement que
c'est des mesures de sobriété donc c'est
des mesures excessives
si vous avez moins de transport aérien
vous avez moins de fabricants d'avions
airbus là ils s'attendent à avoir une
baisse très significative de leurs de
leurs activités vous avez moins de gens
qui sont payés par les compagnies
aériennes
si vous avez moins de touristes qui se
balade donc vous avez moins de gens qui
viennent dans les hôtels cafés
restaurants etc
donc c'est tout à fait possible mais
vous voyez bien qu'il ya une
contrepartie sur l'économie qui est que
ces récessif alors maintenant si on
renverse le problème si on se dit de
toute façon l'économie va pas augmenter
mais va diminuer c'est quoi la bonne
manière de s'organiser qui fait en ce
qui permet de préserver l'essentiel et
l'essentiel pour moi c'est que les gens
continue quand même à avoir confiance en
l'avenir il faut quand même rappeler que
cet épisode va créer à la louche à mon
avis 4 millions de chômeurs
supplémentaires ni vous ni moi n'avons
envie d'être à leur place et c'est
parfaitement légitime donc là la bonne
question c'est comment est ce qu'on fait
en sorte que dans ce monde là les gens
et quand même pas d'emploi c'est ça pour
moi le premier truc absolument centrale
même si ce n'est pas ce qu'ils faisaient
avant
mais il faut absolument qu'ils aient un
emploi et par ailleurs
il faut qu effectivement le monde se
réorganise d'une manière qui est plus
résiliente plus résistantes qui
demandent moins une grande quantité de
matière et d'énergie pour rester en fait
on a créé un monde qui est très
performant en tant qu'il reste dans sa
zone de confort et qui se met à 10
fonctionner très fortement dès qu'on
sort un peu de sa zone de confort et
c'est bien ça le sait bien ça le monde
dans lequel on vit
il faut faire un monde qui acceptent
d'être sorti de sa zone de confort parce
que c'est ça qui va se passer et qui
continue quand même à fonctionner à peu
près correctement
jean marc jancovici est ce que vous ne
redoutez pas et qu'il y ait un moratoire
sur l'écologie comme il ya semble-t-il
un moratoire sur la dette est il que
finalement les politiques décident de
reporter cette transition la plus tard
alors la transition qui reporterait à
plus tard je le redis c'est celle qui
n'a pas d'intérêt pour moi c'est à dire
qu'en france la transition énergétique
qu'on a mise en route l'essentiel des
moyens quand vous regardez où va
l'argent
je ne parle pas des discours mais où va
l'argent l'argent va dans le fait de
faire des éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires
c'est un programme qui n'a d'intérêt sur
aucun point alors je peux les prendre
dans l'ordre oui expédié d'où ça n'a pas
d'intérêt sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre puisque ça vise à
remplacer du nucléaire qui n'émet pas de
co2 il faut rappeler que le nucléaire
consiste à casser en deux des noyaux de
métal l'uranium ça n'est pas équivalent
à oxyder les atomes de carbone donc ça
ne fait pas de co2 et le panache blanc
qu'on voit au dessus des tours de
réfrigération c'est à vapeur d'eau c'est
un refroidir la centrale c'est pas du
tout du co2 des centrales à charbon en
allemagne ont les mêmes panache blanc et
c'est pas de la queue gamme co2 donc le
nucléaire ne fait pas de co2 remplacer
du nucléaire qui ne fait pas de co2 part
de l'éolien ou du photovoltaïque qui
n'en font pas non plus en fonctionnement
ça ne fait rien gagné et comme par
ailleurs il faut dépenser plus de co2
pour faire le panneau pour faire la
centrale nucléaire
en fait ça on peut même perdre quand on
place par du photovoltaïque
la deuxième chose sur laquelle ça fait
pas gagner c'est l'emploi il se trouve
que quand on a une centrale nucléaire on
importe l'uranium mais ça représente
très très peu d'argent par mégawattheure
produit par kilowattheure produit quand
on fait du solaire ou de l'éolien on
importe soit les panneaux soient les
nacelles c'est parfaitement mondialisée
ans et industrie là toutes les dix
premiers fabricants de panneaux sont en
chine
et donc on augmente les importations à
consommation constante et donc ça ça
détruit l'emploi l'économie de base
quand vous en trouvez augmenter les
importations à consommation constante
vous détruisez d'un point ça ne diminue
pas le risque nucléaire parce que vous
allez devoir gardez-vous centrale pour
quand ya pas assez de vente par assez de
soleil c'est ce qu'ont fait les
allemands les allemands ont toujours la
même quantité de centrales dites
conventionnelles
c'est à dire charbon gaz
hydroélectricité nucléaire que avant le
développement de leur programme éolien
et solaire
parce que vous avez besoin d'assurer ce
qu'on appelle le backup la fourniture
d'électricité
comprenez bien que dans l'épisode qu'on
vient de vivre aussi les hôpitaux
n'avaient pas fonctionné quelques mois
il ya du vent ou du soleil on n'aurait
pas trouvé ça très drôle
donc on va garder le même nombre de
centrales mais on va moins les faire
fonctionner puisque quand il aura du
vent et du soleil on fera pas tourner la
centrale or là j'entre à l'état d'en
être un ange et un coût fixe ça vous
coûte la même chose ce qui vous coûte
cher pour une centrale nucléaire c'est à
construire après la faire fonctionner
derrière les gens que ça vous coûtera
les gens qu'il faut payer la maintenance
et l'achat du radium c'est pas cher par
rapport aux coûts de construction donc
que vous en seriez un peu ou beaucoup
toute façon la centrale beaucoup de la
même chose par contre si vous vous en
servez - elle vous rapporte moins
donc vous avez moins d'argent pour
l'entretenir donc le grand paradoxe est
que développe et du solaire et de
l'éolien augmente le risque nucléaire et
non pas le baisse pas ses farces
donc en fait c'est un truc de shadocks
ce qu'on est en train de faire c'est
l'exact exemple on n'a pas compris le
problème posé
et cet argent là pendant ce temps là en
plus cet argent là maintenant est
prélevée sur les carburants
l'argent qui sert à développer des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires il ne
sert évidemment pas à permettre au gilet
jaune de rouler pour moins cher
penser ça qu'il faut faire avec cet
argent là donc il faut faire alors ou de
la voiture électrique si c'est pas c'est
pas cher plus sûr pour beaucoup plus
simplement de la petite voiture
le truc le plus évident pour remplacer
une voiture qui consomme 6 liszt et de
la remplacer par une voiture qui
concerne 2 litres/100 kittin et à faire
de l'électricité ça ça divise d'un
facteur 3 le pétrole dont on a besoin et
les émissions qui vont derrière et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on pourrait
mettre en oeuvre demain matin donc il ya
aussi le passage sur le vélo le vélo
électrique en particulier est quelque
chose qui a un potentiel très important
dès que vous avez 10 15 km à faire parce
que c'est un vélo sans effort
le problème du vélo électrique c'est de
construire des pistes cyclables pour
avoir voirie séparés pour les vo alors
je vais vous donner un ordre de grandeur
avec l'argent qu'on a déjà mis déjà mis
déjà promis de mettre dans l'éolien et
le solaire afin 2018
c'est à dire 120 milliards d'euros je
dis bien 120 milliards d'euros
on aurait pu doubler tout km de routes
en france d'une piste cyclable mais le
roi y est allé de dunkerque à menton en
vélo sans avoir besoin de croiser la
moindre voiture donc on a aussi besoin
d'infrastructures pour développer le dos
à ces parfaites pour relancer le btp
pour coup mieux que de faire des ronds
points
donc vous avez on peut très bien faire
des choses qui sont des choses qui
permettent de ceux de se passer
progressivement de pétrole donc là je
viens de vous donner deux ou trois
exemples justement une question alors je
vais pas à nouveau vous parlez de
nucléaire parce que la dernière fois
qu'on s'était entretenu sur les zones le
mot nucléaire que j'avais prononcé ne
vous avais pas convenu mais ça veut dire
jean marc jancovici et que l'on
abandonnerait l'éolien et le
photovoltaïque au profit donc d'une
prolongation
la durée de vie des centrales pour y est
absolument toutes les centrales qui
exercent aux états qui opère aux états
unis dont une centaine de réacteurs nous
on en a un peu moins de 60 les les
américains les ont déjà prolongé à 60
ans il ya des exploitants qui sont en
train de demander la prolongation à 80
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que dans une
centrale nucléaire en fait la notion
d'âge n'a pas vraiment de sens parce
qu'au fur et à mesure que le central
avance vous remplacer les équipements
fessenheim au moment où elle a été
fermée d'une manière parfaitement
arbitraire par le par le gouvernement
qui s'est dépêché de faire perdre à la
région quelques milliers d'emplois juste
avant la crise du co lead voilà les
impressions c'est une centrale dans
laquelle tous les équipements d'origine
avait échangé sauf la cuve
c'est le seul équipement donc là qu ils
vont la surveille et puis si jamais il
ya un problème la marette mais dans le
mondial quand j'ai pas d'exemple en tête
sauf en belgique éventuellement où on
est où on est dit on retire la centrale
du service parce que la cuve présente
des faiblesses le donc le à part ça tout
le reste vous pouvez changer
c'est un peu comme une voiture où j'ai
envie de dire au cours de la durée de
vie de la voiture vous ne garderez que
le châssis et puis tout le reste les
portières de voiteur le volant tout vous
changer au fur et à mesure donc là nous
tend quand vous êtes dans ce genre de
système la notion d'âge n'a pas
tellement de sens donc ce qui se passe
en france c'est que tous les dix ans
vous avez l'asn l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire qui passe voir à quoi
ressemble votre voiture votre centrale
nucléaire et qui vous dit ça c'est
encore bon pour le service ou pas pour
dix ans de plus donc au moment où on
construit la centrale
absolument pas 40 ans garanti qu il ya
l'asn qui passe qui vous dit on pour dix
ans picard passe dix ans après en disant
bon pour dix ans pas et c est donc dans
ce genre de contexte
vous pouvez très bien prolonger les
centrales à 60 ans si à chaque fois que
vous faites ce qu'il faut pour que
forrest est pas ça qui très bien bon
pour dix ans est ce qu'on aurait de plus
intelligent et le moins cher à faire
dans notre pays c'est bien évidemment ce
genre de choses et en parallèle il faut
se mettre en mesure de remplacer ces
réacteurs parce qu'ils finiront par
arriver quand même un jour en bout de
course par d'autres réacteurs pour
lesquels soit dit en passant le p r et
pas nécessairement la meilleure option
mais ça c'est un départ un peu technique
interne à la filière et je suis tout à
fait partisan de remplacer ce duke les
airs à d'autres du clae r parce que
quand vous regardez bien les paramètres
environnementaux c'est de très loin ce
qui est le plus intéressant pour
l'environnement un point important par
exemple il faut 1000 fois plus de
surface mille fois plus de surface pour
faire la même quantité d'électricité
dans l'année en solaire que en nucléaire
mille fois plus de surface aux sols
artificialisés donc il faut entre 10 et
100 fois plus de métal par kilowattheure
produit quand vous utilisez de l'éolien
avoue du solaire qui exploite des
énergies très diffuse que quand vous
utilisez du nucléaire qui est une
énergie très concentré donc le nucléaire
a des tas davantage
il n'a pas que des inconvénients loin
s'en faut et nos prédécesseurs ils ont
fait des tas de trucs idiots mais il ya
aussi des trucs qu'ils ont fait n'était
pas si idiot que ça et le nucléaire est
plutôt à ranger dans cette catégorie
bon j'espère que nous aurons l'occasion
d'évoquer les conclusions du shift
project lorsque vous aurez
et terminer donc cette étude et les
différents processus de transformation
énergétique
une question en conclusion jean marc
jancovici est ce que vous n'avez pas
peur que cette crise par rapport donc à
une urgence sanitaire fasse oublier l
urgence climatique est ce que vous allez
faire revoit aujourd'hui pas je ne peux
alors à chacun voit midi à sa porte
avec les points ne sont que j'ai à titre
personnel je ne crois pas je crois que
la crise au contraire je pense que ce
qui est en train de se passer en ce
moment fait prendre conscience du fait
que on peut avoir des surprises très
désagréable quand on n'a pas pensé à
l'avance à se prémunir contre un certain
nombre de risques et il me semble au
contraire que le sujet environnemental
émergent plutôt dans les préoccupations
sur lesquels les gens ont des
convictions renforcée en ce moment donc
que au niveau du gouvernement il soit
pas capable dans l'urgence de faire
autre chose que d'essayer de faire
repartir ce qui existe déjà
moi ça me paraît normal du reste on
m'avait demandé ce que j'en pensais il
ya quelques semaines juste après le
début de la crise j'ai dit c'est
exactement comme ça que ça va se passer
parce que vous ne faites pas le plan b
dans l'urgence soit plat qui est déjà
fait avant soit vous l'avez pas fait et
si vous l'avez pas fait vous vous dites
que la manière la plus simple que de
remettre les gens au travail parce que
c'est ça qui est en tête des gouvernants
et c'est légitime c'est normal que les
gens étaient un emploi encore une fois
c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils
refassent ce qu'ils savaient déjà faire
ce qui revient à dire qu'on repart comme
avant mais je ne crois pas du tout que
en termes de préoccupation la
préoccupation environnementale soit
passé au deuxième rang je ne crois pas
je crois qu'au contraire une partie des
gens se disent bien tant qu'art et en
tant qu à repartir de l'avant en
essayant de repartir de façon différente
bon rendez vous bientôt jean marc
jancovici pour voir ce qui va se
dérouler dans les prochaines semaines
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nous je
rappelle que vous présidez le film tant
que shift project dans quelques instants
nous serons en compagnie de nos
camarades de la séquence ttc 8h47 sur
france culture